bienvenue dans un cri connecte à 89 ans
paul biya cumule plus de 39 ans de
pouvoir à la tête du cameroun et l'ue
pour la dernière fois en 2018 qu'elles
font ses intentions pour 2025 est il
possible d'envisager l'après biya au
cameroun le président lui-même lé
envisage-t-il on en parle tout de suite
et on se connecte depuis douala avec
notre invité je dois aussi vice
président du social democratic front un
parti à d'opposition historique cameroun
est fondée par john fru n'di bonjour à
vous joshua osih et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans afrique
connecte sur arte france bonjour à vous
et bonjour tous les téléspectateurs
de rtl france et de l'émission offrit
connexes alors on va se projeter pour
commencer jose va ou zid quelle est
votre vision de l'après biya m'écouter
elle est
je dirais un tout petit peu flou parce
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde sait qui
aura un après biya mais tous ceux qui
sont autour du prix zambie à fond comme
si ça n'existera jamais et donc on a un
très gros problème parce que c'est un
débat qui est plus ou moins de tabous au
cameroun et
on est en train d'arriver à la fin d'un
cycle et je dirais même qu'on est au
bord du précipice
et c'est extrêmement dangereux parce que
il y a autour de biya y'a rien qui
semble en fait il n'y a pas
d'institutions fortes il n'y a pas de
personnalité forte qui pourrait
dans la limite de la légalité
faire ses 140 jours de transition
politique nécessaire pour arriver à une
élection donc nous craignons que si rien
n'est fait et si ces institutions
républicaines et les personnes qui les
incarnent surtout ne sont pas renforcées
on risque d'avoir une situation où soit
la rue où l'armée devrait prendre ses
responsabilités je suis un homme
politique
je suis vice présent d'un parti
politique républicain je ne veux pas que
cela arrive et c'est pour cela que nous
dépensons beaucoup d'énergie et beaucoup
de temps pour faire en sorte qu'ils
véritable transition politique au
cameroun et je crois que il ya aussi un
mélange un peu de de problèmes parce que
ceux qui aujourd'hui sont au pouvoir ont
une crainte bleus d'une sorte de justice
transitionnelle et donc essaye de
freiner à tout prix le fait
de parler ou alors d'organiser cette
transition pour qu'elles se passent de
façon politique alors je vous propose
d'écouter
charlemagne pascal messanga nyamding qui
va intervenir tout au long de l'émission
les politologues mettra de conférences
en sciences politiques et en droit
public des yayistes surtout et membre du
comité central du rdpc le rassemblement
démocratique du peuple camerounais le
parti au pouvoir au cameroun il ya
certes depuis 39 ans un président à la
tête de votre pays mais existe-t-il un
système biya qui verrouille tout je lui
ai posé la question on écoute il existe
deux systèmes démocratiques que ni par
un chef d'état qui a été
démocratiquement élu depuis le 6
novembre
1982 je crois que le cameroun
aujourd'hui si on peut parler des
systèmes biya c'est un système
démocratique ouvert où plus de 200
partis politiques serré valises sont en
rivalité avec une assemblée qui déplut
près de 40 ans compte à peu près une
dizaine de partis qui se sont présentés
à la députation et au sénat alors pas de
système d'ia mais un système
démocratique qui repose sur la pléthore
de partis politiques
selon pascal messanga nyamding votre
réaction écoutez il est dans son rôle
quand il dit cela
je dirai tout simplement que je
n'attendais pas plus venant de lui
aujourd'hui si on veut parler de
démocratie on doit reconnaître que une
institution un pays véritablement
démocratique se donnent
des 20 euros pour pouvoir garantir cette
démocratie un des verrous très très
important surtout dans les démocraties
naissantes comme celle du cameroun c'est
la limitation des mandats je crois que
notre démocratie est née avec la
constitution de 96 avec des limitations
de mandat et monsieur biya l'a fait
sauter et pour rester aussi longtemps
possible il faut noter que dans une
démocratie si on quand on a un système
démocratique
un système démocratique doit aux minima
pouvoir garantir des alternances à tous
les niveaux au niveau des municipales
des législatifs et c'est ce qui n'est
pas le cas au cameroun aujourd'hui au
cameroun nous nous battons encore pour
la dame pour l'avènement de la
démocratie et je crois que pascal mais
ça valait 1 din confond multipartisme et
démocratie ce sont deux concepts bien
différent et comment fonctionne ce
système paul biya qui sont ces garants
mais écoutez je pense que le
président biya a une chance
particulière au cameroun c'est que son
prédécesseur qu'il n'a pas beaucoup aimé
a garanti à travers la révolution verte
une autosuffisance alimentaire qui
existe quoi qu'on en dise donc les
camerounais n'ont pas faim les besoins
de base se trouve aussi plus ou moins
disponibles pour les camerounaises et
les camerounais donc il n'y a pas une
urgence politique pour changer le il
faut aussi dire que le pouvoir fait tout
pour déconstruire toute revendication
pour un meilleur pouvoir d'achat et
ce pouvoir pendant 40 ans a aussi des
construit tout notre identité nationale
qui avait été forgée les 30 années avant
lui et donc l'absence d'une identité
nationale on est dans une situation de
multitude de nations que d'autres voient
rappelés des tribus et donc les gens
s'occupent plus de leur tribu plutôt que
du pays et on peut le dire pour que les
téléspectateurs le comprennent je dis
souvent qu'on a l'impression que la
direction de notre pays c'est un peu
comme l'onu tout le monde sait que ça
existe tout le monde sait qu'on est
membre mais personne n'y croit vraiment
et personnes s'occupent vraiment de ce
qui se passe là-bas donc c'est un peu on
a souvent on associe souvent le cameroun
à la
françafrique justement quelle est la
contribution de 2 du système
de la françafrique a perduré pour
certains qui perdure encore sur le
continent au système biya écoutez la
françafrique est omniprésente vous savez
mon parti politique et contre le franc
cfa du mois on n'est pas contre une
monnaie commune en afrique encore moins
une monnaie commune en afrique centrale
et en afrique de l'ouest mais nous
sommes contre l'absence de souveraineté
de notre monnaie nous sommes contre
l'absence de souveraineté de notre
économie nous nous battons contre tout
cela et nous pensons aussi que c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes
dans l'opposition depuis 30 ans
aujourd'hui parce que la françafrique
est présente qu'on le veuille ou pas et
le cameroun est un maillon essentiel de
cette françafrique en afrique centrale
vous savez si le cameroun s'écroule la
centrafrique n'existe plus le dab on
s'écroule tout de suite après le congo
brazza et le tchad n'en parlons même pas
donc il est important que pour ses
intérêts là que le seul garant de ce
système de cette françafrique reste en
place aussi longtemps possible mais
maintenant si on ne garantit pas une
transition politique
je pense que ce système de la
françafrique au cameroun exactement dans
la même situation que la classe
politique camerounaise c'est à dire
nous sommes dans
nous nous préparons pour un chaos
certain alors on associe le cameroun à
la françafrique mais aussi à la
corruption il faut quand même
reconnaître que le président camerounais
paul biya a lancé l'opération épervier
pour lutter contre ce mal ce mal au sein
des élites politiques et économiques on
va écouter à ce propos le biais liste
pascal messanga nyamding le bilan est
bon mais il ya des résistances vous
savez l'opération épervier c'est ce que
vous confrères au cameroun ont baptisée
opération épervier mais c'est une
campagne d'assainissement d'élite a
lancé par le président paul biya en
mettant en place plusieurs instruments
institutionnalisé qui lutte contre la
corruption vous avez la conac
il vous avez également
l'anif et bien d'autres structures
interministérielles malheureusement
certains camerounais ont la tête dure
notamment les fonctionnaires qui sont
malheureusement très corrompu ça il faut
le reconnaître et ben le président
continue à mener cette lutte mais on
peut faire un bilan le président en près
de 40 ans a utilisé à peu près 500
ministre est membre du gouvernement il
n'y a pas 10 % qui sont en prison tous
les réseaux ne voulons c'est pourquoi je
pense que effectivement ça se passe très
bien et a espoir si vous avez à peine
10% les personnes qui détourné les fonds
et qui sont appréhendés c'est plutôt une
bonne chose pour le cameroun alors josé
rosie l'opération épervier c'est une
opération d'assainissement au plus haut
niveau à une chasse aux sorcières contre
les opposants et les potentiels rivaux
comme certains l'affirment notamment les
détracteurs de paul biya m'écouter
oui et non nous savons très bien au
cameroun et je pense que 24 millions de
cas monde et partagent cet avis compris
le présent bien lui-même que il ya
plusieurs personnes qui vivent au delà
et de noix au delà leurs possibilités
leur train de vie et de loin ou de l'un
de leurs ressources mais ils sont
inquiétés pour des raisons politiques
donc il y à une chasse aux sorcières il
ya surtout des règlements de comptes
politiques et surtout un positionnement
politique c'est à dire qu'on déclenche
l'opération à chaque fois qu'il ya une
petite graine
pouvoir a pesé les populations donc le
but recherché avec cette opération ce
n'est pas d'assainir les finances
publiques loin de là je au parlement
nous le répétons tous les jours et à
pascal charlemagne le sait très bien
nous venant de la même région nous
venons nous partageons les mêmes
origines et chez nous nous disons que le
poisson pourrit par la tête donc s'il
veut véritablement nettoyer qui commence
par la tête on ne commence pas par là
que quand on a un poisson
qui commencent à pourrir donc il est
évident aujourd'hui et tout le monde le
sait qui a
un problème de détournement de fonds
grave au cameroun j'aimerais juste
précisé que nous parlons toujours de
corruption à ma connaissance il ya peu
de camerounais en prison il n'y a pas de
personnes en prison au cameroun pour
corruption apporte m'en parler c'est
pour des détournements de fonds et ses
détournements de fonds pour qu'il cesse
il faut changer le système
administratif c'est à dire que vous ne
pouvez pas être président de la
république ministre après ministres
entrent dans le même bureau arrive à
détourner des milliards et vous ne
changez pas le système qui leur permet
de détourner ces milliards parce que les
mettre en prison c'est une chose mais il
faut aussi qu'on ait un audit de nos
finances publiques qu'on ait un audit de
de nos systèmes de oui il ya eu des
améliorations dans les passations de
marchés etc mais ça ne suffit toujours
pas et voyez vous pour vous apporter la
preuve
nous nous sommes battus au niveau du
parlement l'opposition pour arriver vers
une économie cash laisse où nous passons
un peu comme à l'image du rwanda ou le
mobile money et les cartes de crédit et
cetera tous les autres moyens de
paiement qui arrive à freiner cette
corruption endémique et le dessus sur le
reste nous nous réjouissons que le
ministère des finances par exemple au
niveau des impôts donne aujourd'hui la
possibilité de payer par voie
électronique et digital ses impôts
quelles que soient les montants mais
grande fut notre surprise que haut dé
que les camerounais ont adopté les
moyens de paiement di vito le
gouvernement a décidé d'introduire dans
sa loi de finances 2005 de une taxe sur
ces pays on l'a donc pour faire en sorte
que ces moyens existent mais coûte plus
cher que si vous allez vers le cash et
ça démontre à merveille que le
gouvernement veut rester dans le cachet
veux quand tu es à détourner et les
montants qui sont détournés aujourd'hui
sont ahurissants je pense qu'on détourne
plus d'argent que le budget
d'investissement de la république par
année je sois aussi on va marquer à une
courte pause et se retrouver dans un
instant pour poursuivre dans afrique
connecte à rester avec nous
retour dans afrique connecte sur arte
france nous sommes avec je dois aussi le
vice président du social democratic
front on évoque avec lui l'après biya il
est à douala le pouvoir camerounais quel
confrontée à d'importants défis
sécuritaires comme ses voisins dans la
sous région notamment avec boko haram
mais il faut citer également à la crise
anglophones dans le nord-ouest et le
sud-ouest du pays le nose au une vaste
zone riche en pétrole l'an bazzoli un
état autoproclamé on parle de crise mais
aussi de véritables guerres civiles
alors pourquoi la crise anglophone
perdurer coûté la vie du bia liste
pascal messanga nyamding et perdure pour
ce que plus de raison d'envoyer les
causes exogènes
voyez vous dans cette cause et les
causes endogènes causes exogènes comment
pouvez-vous comprendre que au moment où
on suit la scène internationale les
etats-unis la france et tous les pays de
l' ocde se bat pour neutraliser les
terroristes et malheureusement en
afrique il n'y a que des guerres au délà
du cameroun joue chez des remarques qui
à la guerre au mali qui à la guerre ou
chat qui à la guerre en république
centrafricaine le pensons franchement
que il ya un enjeu
malheureusement où les armes sont
vendues par les pays les plus riches qui
ont fait de la guerre une espèce de
rentes pour relancer leur économie on ne
peut pas le comprendre on ne peut pas
comprendre que un pays comme le cameroun
qui luttent et qui contribuent à lutter
contre le terrorisme avait ses
partenaires bilatéraux c'est à dire les
états amis comme la france l'angleterre
est haute et que malheureusement ces
états hébergent tous ceux qui financent
le terrorisme
dans la zone anglophone je vous prends
un exemple il ya une organisation
terroriste qui s'appelle embase unadif
en force son leader à wattrelos classe
iv ou en norvège et actrice anneaux et
aélita tôt et bien d'autres outils
finances a battu ducasse en euros
d'ailleurs battu lukas à poindre qui
finance l'autre organisme terroriste mon
cher monsieur
comment comprendre que nos partenaires
bilatéraux ne neutralisent pas ces gens
en les estrades ans imaginez vous un
tant soit peu sur venez dire aux
américains que oussama ben laden vit
au cameroun c'est sur un scandale dont
vous voyez donc que malheureusement le
partenaire mais grandes puissances
veulent recruter ni cette guerre pour
des raisons géopolitiques pour des
raisons de pétrole bien entendu aussi il
ya des causes endogènes je reconnais que
le président paul biya a fait énormément
d'efforts avec le grand dialogue
national
malheureusement il ya aussi des
extrémistes comme dans tous les pays du
monde qui est en cours seul objectif de
voir pour lui à partir je sois ausy
alors est ce que vous partagez la vie
l'analyse de pascal messanga nyamding et
d'ailleurs est ce qu'un changement à la
tête de l'état camerounais peut
permettre réellement de régler le
conflit et de satisfaire aussi à la
minorité anglophone qui se sent
marginalisé
écoutez je pense que oui je pense que
c'est même cela aujourd'hui l'urgence je
pense qu'on essaye de garder en fait le
régime des ongs et c'est le dernier un
certain statu quo sur la situation pour
essayer de faire que ça se dégrade pas
plus mais il devra aussi reconnaître que
la situation est complètement invivable
pour les populations
qui sont et pour les populations
originaires
de ces deux régions donc il est il est
évident aujourd'hui je le dis souvent
pour le caricaturer que si on annonce le
départ de monsieur biya c'est certain
que les militaires
déployés sur le champ des sur les champs
de bataille et les sécessionnistes vont
probablement fêter cette nouvelle dans
les mêmes bars parce que nous avons dans
tout le cameroun plus ou moins les mêmes
problèmes et dans le sud ouest et le
nord ouest ces deux régions d'origine
anglophone il ya un problème politique
spécifique c'est à dire que c'est une
partie qui est venu rejoindre le reste
du cameroun sur la base d'un contrat qui
aujourd'hui n'est plus respectée j'en
veux pour preuve si vous regardez le
protocole l'état les sept personnalités
de l'état il n'y a aucun anglophone vous
ne pouvez pas joindre deux partis
ensemble dans laquelle en est dans ce
contrat qui est la nouvelle constitution
fédérale l'état la nature fédérale de
l'état camerounais ne peut être touché
c'est l'article 48 de la constitution de
60 72 et que celui là même qui a signé
cette constitution décide de se faire un
coup d'état lui-même pour mettre en
place un état unifié comme il l'appelle
mso fait un étage la peau bas et c'est
contre cela que les gens se battent
maintenant règle est claire et je suis
d'accord avec mes soldats nième des qui
a des extrémistes de tous bords dans le
régime de yaoundé est aussi dans les
comment dirais-je dans le problème
anglophone c'est à dire ce qu'est une
instrumentalisation qui vient de
l'extérieur aussi dans le but de
déstabiliser le cameroun bien sûr il ya
tout le monde qui puis à tout le monde
qu'ils profitent donc y en a qui
veulent maintenant prendre une
un combat qui était noble c'est à dire
de remettre en place les accords près 72
ou les accords de 61 pour que les deux
zones se sentent tous comme et faisant
partie
tu m'aimes pays c'est à dire la zone
francophone et anglophone il ya ce débat
là il est omniprésent et c'est un débat
noble parce que le sud ouest le nord
oues et rattachés au reste du cameroun à
travers un contrat qui était une
constitution fédérale et ça c'est devant
il y retourner mais maintenant il est
clair qu'il y à des puissances
étrangères qui en profite il est
abondamment documenté qu' il fallait à
tout prix assimiler les anglophones et
ça venait tout droit de paris et il ya
assez de documentation là dessus sur le
sujet donc il ne fait aucun doute
aujourd'hui que il y a des forces
endogènes extrêmement forte mais je suis
intéressé au bilan économique de paul
biya le président paul biya qui a lancé
un programme à émergence a avec des
résultats à l'horizon 2035 alors quel
bilan justement voix slaves gracia en
pleine crise économique avec la chute
des cours du pétrole depuis la moitié
des années 80 paul biya lance en 2012 un
ambitieux programme émergence
objectif faire du cameroun un pays
émergent à l'horizon 2035
de quoi s'agit-il c'est un vaste plan
économique par étape fondée sur
plusieurs piliers l'environnement avec
la préservation des écosystèmes
l'industrie avec la construction de
barrages hydroélectriques ou la santé
avec l'amélioration de structures
sanitaires hospitalière des promesses de
développement sur du long terme mais
avec peu d'impact direct sur les
populations féminines bercy observé on
ne souligne que le président biya a
dérivé dire ce qu'on veut c'est pouvoir
et nommé nommé de gouvernement démission
mais les objectifs assignés à ces
différents gouvernements ne sont pas
atteints notamment sur le plan
économique et même une présentation
d'une façon durable qui pourrait
permettre le décollage de la croissance
entre 2009 et 2014 le cameroun profite
d'une croissance de 1,9 à 5,9 pour cent
paul biya décide d'emprunter de l'argent
sur les marchés internationaux pour
financer son programme de développement
par le biais d'une obligation publique
un euro bond de 450 milliards de francs
cfa une opération réussie selon les
autorités camerounaises qui ont annoncé
en 2021 leur financement de cet orgue
ondes grâce à la confiance des
investisseurs des investisseurs attirés
par la dette des pays émergents est
rassuré par la signature d'un programme
stratégique de développement avec le
fonds monétaire international
j'ai reçu une dette abyssale la balance
commerciale est déficitaire alors au
pays se tourne une fois de plus ouvert
les partenaires que sont notamment fait
la france vos partenaires j'ai divers
numéros par les institutions de bretton
woods et cela a considérablement
augmenté la dette et du cajon dire
si j'ai aujourd'hui
de 4000 j'ai tiré mais n'a que deux ans
et phare reste l'impact réel sur les
populations secteur des transports
toujours en grande difficulté un système
de santé en berne les autorités
camerounaises elle avance une
conjoncture peu favorable
insécurité crise sanitaire chute des
cours du pétrole alors à tort ou à
raison
en soit autrement dit que ce soit à tort
parce que le cameroun a fait divers est
plus tourné vers les exportations ce que
comme on a dénoncé le fait que c'est
pour agir c'est à dire soit l'occasion
ont l'habitude du crès à vire l'élite
politico administratives que ce soit
l'occasion pour eux de procéder à des
détournements massifs la corruption
justement elle reste endémique dans ce
pays classé trois fois champion du monde
en la matière dernière polémique en date
les projets d'infrastructure de la coupe
d'afrique des nations un coût estimé à
près de 500 milliards de francs cfa
d'investissement
là encore les autorités camerounaises la
firme la can aura un impact sur
l'économie du pays avec une dette de 40
% du produit intérieur brut le géant
vale est il vraiment la chandelle
affaire à suivre
josé après biya ou pas il faudra
composer avec ce programme émergence
pour revenir sur la situation économique
du cameroun on ne peut pas il faudrait
un véritable plan marshall pour s'en
sortir au moins pour revenir à la où on
était avant l'arrivée de monsieur biya
et puis de prendre un nouveau départ
parce que voyez-vous le pouvoir d'achat
baisser la qualité de vie à baisser
l'endettement
qui était presque inexistant aujourd'hui
est presque insoutenable les inégalités
sociales gens parlent même plus et c'est
terrible la justice sociale est
complètement absente on le voit tous les
niveaux surtout à l'accès aux emplois et
aux emplois publics la balance
commerciale est déficitaire les
infrastructures de base en des classes
la raison primaires et je crois que vaut
mon prédécesseur l'a si bien dit de la
réseau primaire où les raisons
fondamentales pour lesquelles
l'entourage de monsieur via le pousse à
aller danser grand projet c'est de créer
des robinets de détournement de créer
des opportunités de détournement de
fonds et aujourd'hui nous avons les
routes les plus chères au monde les
ponts les plus chères au monde
les stades les plus chers au monde et
est en continu
aller dans ce sens là c'est à dire on
continue sans véritablement se poser les
vraies questions c'est pourquoi est ce
que ces routes sont si chers pourquoi
est ce que ces ponts sont aussi chers
ces stades sont si chers personnes au
niveau de yaoundé veut se poser les
vraies questions on essaye de voir
qu'ils détournent oui on sait qu'après
la can de trois personnes aux 4 5 iront
en prison mais ça ne change pas le fond
le fond est là et qui a tout un régime
qui bénéficient de ces détournements et
qui essayent d'amasser des fortunes
colossales justement
cette transition je vis pour terminer
selon pascal messanga nyamding paul biya
n'a pas l'intention de s'éterniser au
pouvoir votre avis là-dessus et aussi de
l'opposition qui subit aussi une
certaine forme de répression notamment
on l'a vu avec l'un de vos rivaux
l'opposant maurice kamto c'est à un ex
ministre du camp biya qui aujourd'hui et
connaît des déboires avec la justice
écoutez c'est peut-être un rival mais
pas un adversaire donc
les déboires avec la justice nous sdf on
les connaît depuis 1990 nous avons eu
plusieurs de nos militants aussi exécuté
par ce régime et de nombreuses autres
ont tout perdu et ont passé de
nombreuses années en prison donc c'est
pas quelque chose qui date d'aujourd'hui
il n'y avait pas de réseaux sociaux à
l'époque c'est peut-être pour cela qu'on
le regarde différemment mais monsieur
biya il est clair qu'ils n'envisagent
pas une vie à côté du pouvoir en tout
cas rien ne le démontrent nous étions au
stade lors de l'ouverture de la câble je
crois que les gens ne le savent pas mais
les populations applaudissait messieurs
biya parce qu'ils disaient tous du moins
ça se chuchotait dans les gradins
j'étais présent qu'il est en train de
nous dire au revoir et donc que les gens
étaient contents qu'ils viennent
finalement nous dire au revoir au stade
vous savez la tannerie son dernier de
gros projets son dernier drobo b donc
les populations
exalté dans les tribunes en se disant
qu'ils nous disent au revoir mais moi je
crois le contraire il n'y a absolument
aucun plan de partir et d'ailleurs j'en
veux pour preuve il ya déjà une équipe
au niveau de la présidence qui
travaillent sur 2025 donc comment est ce
qu'ils vont représenter
comment est-ce qu'ils vont vouloir
passer une nouvelle fois
sans utiliser les leviers démocratique
pour donner un autre mandat à un énième
mandat au président biya j'en sais rien
mais il est évident qu'il n'a aucun plan
de partir aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup à vous a choisi je vous
en prie merci est très bonne journée et
merci pour le nord que vous faites à
voir sur arte france on va aussi
remercié le bédéiste pascal messanga
nyamding pour ses interventions merci
aux équipes du mag et aux équipes
techniques
retrouver après connecte sur nos réseaux
sociaux et notre site arte france point
tv merci de votre attention
à très bientôt dans un pré collecte sur
rt france
[Musique]